you go first
potentially there could be some
controversial like things that we
haven't even eaten before so I'm pretty
excited I'm kind of nervous
bring it on Philippines we're ready so
this is seasick pigs is immediately
turned me off it looks like something
that I've have eaten before it around 2
3 a.m. in the morning smells super
fragrant Cheers
but it's very rubbery very soft that's
really good no even no one told me that
this was like the ear of a pig I just be
like yeah I'm just eating bacon
I don't do this anyway I would order
that off the menu if I saw pig's ear but
I'm tasting it it's definitely something
I would go again
Thanks Filipinos I know I've eaten pig's
ears are they like a superfood will I
get like really good skin chicken adobo
no I can't say that that sounds so
boyish oh I can smell it already
is something like mysterious about this
one too nervous you're nervous it's just
chicken
it tastes like teriyaki chicken like you
know the chicken inside the sushi rolls
yeah I'd order that yeah I think it's
really good I think that this is a Nero
sinigang Nikita was I close there are
two huge prawns in the middle of is
falling I honestly wouldn't even know
how to shell a prawn okay bad Australian
it smells a bit like an aquarium fryer
sweat from a boot poured into a bottle a
sweat from a boot so if you're sitting
down and eating this soup you're gonna
be like eating soup but then also like
shelling prawns and then going back to
eating a soup it's still tasty prole
imagine eating this on like a first date
and you have to get your hands in your
soup and like okay all these prawns in
front of someone it's a note from me
so this is gutter cutter and this is bug
on and this is like shrimp paste
apparently and this is oxtail and ox
tribe it actually just smells like
peanut butter or rubbery so cool
zipper on it still on it still to be
honest I don't know what an ox is I
think the ox is okay look everything
else so far has been great but just
let's get the trade next time so this is
Dino go on and it's pig's blood at least
it's not like red you know what if you
hadn't told me that was pig blood I'd be
like oh yeah I need more of that
I think the blood made the dish more
exciting and there's a certain smell to
it as well that you can smell even when
it's in your mouth that looks a mess
tastes a treat I would not have this
again because it's terrifying I would
order it for sure we aren't the boom
oh yeah I know I don't like a hostage
today I was actually kind of impressed I
thought I'd hate everything some unique
ingredients I think that Filipino is a
courageous some of the food that they
put in their mouths but on the whole
actually completely delish